dans les citrouilles des enfants la
gomme ballon aura une place de choix
dans les prochains jours mais les
adultes eux ont moins de réflexe de
sortir de dollars pour acheter
spontanément de la gomme à mâcher qui
tremble malgré tout au caisses des
épiceries dépanneurs et station-servées
il vit soudain devant lui une belle
truite sautée
[Musique]
les géants de la gomme à mâcher nous
vantent l'avantage d'avoir une haleine
fraîche la mauvaise haleine n'est pas
sexy la laine fraîche si mais avec la
pandémie le marché de la gomme a changé
comme la constater cette expert en
marketing une des raisons c'est parce
que il y a effectivement moins de
rencontres sociales comme la gomme est
devenue un outil pour rafraîchir la
laine et rentrer en relation on a vu
quand les gens ont télétravailler tout
d'un coup leur Allen c'était moins
important et on a vu une baisse
significative des ventes de
commandements mais c'est aussi parce
qu'il passait moins pour le magasin il
faisait moins de visites condensait
leurs achats la chute du tabagisme y est
aussi pour quelque chose
comme il y a moins de gens qui fument
beaucoup de fumeurs utilisent après la
cigarette une gomme pour compenser leur
odeur là si vous voulez et on voit avec
la diminution du tabagisme que ça a un
impact sur la commande
ce n'est donc pas étonnant que les
ventes et chutées les chefs de 2019
c'est un marché américain d'à peu près 3
milliards de dollars lagaba marché on
est plus autour de deux points 3 2.5
présentement si on regarde notre année
aujourd'hui deux gros joueurs se
partagent le marché réglé et mandelise
c'est un marché que c'est beaucoup en
solidaire majeurs ont racheté des plus
petits joueurs il y a encore beaucoup de
d'offres de marque et de saveurs mais
ils appartiennent au même aux deux gros
tronclomérats on voit émerger sur
Internet une catégorie de gomme à
laquelle on ajoute des aliments
fonctionnels comme les vitamines la
taurine ou la caféine les aliments
fonctionnels au-delà de l'aliment on
ajoute des trucs qui sont bons pour
votre santé ou qui ont une fonction dans
le reste de votre journée la chimiste
Anne-Marie des biens remarque
effectivement la gomme est de plus en
plus utilisée différemment
il y a une gomme qui va être calmement
donc avec la mélatonine à l'intérieur on
pense à la gomme pour arrêter de fumer
qui contient la nicotine donc on va
vraiment se servir du véhicule de la
gomme pour pouvoir libérer
tranquillement des substances qu'on veut
assimiler
peu importe leur fonction toutes les
gommes sur le marché sont composées de
deux types d'aliments il y a les
aliments solubles qui seront absorbés
par l'organisme tels que les sucres les
édulcorants comme l'aspartame et les
arômes souvent les gommes ils vont se
vanter d'être sans sucre le premier
ingrédient c'est souvent l'exilitol on
va mettre des secrets école donc ils
finissent par le mot hall donc zilitol
mannitol sorbitol donc c'est des sucs
naturels ce qui proviennent souvent des
végétaux comme par exemple l'exilitol
vient de du boulot donc c'est tout à
fait naturel en se solubilisant dans
notre bouche c'est vraiment le
groupement alcool dans la molécule qui
va donner comme une sensation de
fraîcheur
et il y a les aliments insolubles qui ne
seront pas absorbés par le corps comme
la base de gomme synthétique qui peut
contenir jusqu'à 46 ingrédients
à la base de gomme c'est un secret
industriel et puis les entreprises ne
veulent pas aller dans les détails de
qu'est-ce que ça contient pour préserver
leur avantage on peut mettre parfois de
la cire des émulsifiants aussi pour
qu'elle ait une bonne texture qu'elle
soit moelleuse et peu de gens savent
qu'il marche des sous-produits du
pétrole
la gomme a marché peut compter du
pétrole dans la phase insoluble donc on
n'est pas se poser manger même si on la
mange elle ne sera pas digérer donc ce
n'est pas préoccupant pour la santé
actuellement mais ce qui est dommage par
contre c'est qu'on pourra pas le savoir
dans en regardant l'étiquette donc ce
n'est pas mentionné comme le cet
ingrédient là les Léa stomer qui donne
l'élasticité fait partie de la base de
gomme qui figure dans les exceptions où
on a pas obligé légalement d'écrire
exactement toutes les molécules qui se
retrouvent à l'intérieur
on voit maintenant apparaître sur le
marché des gommes se vantant d'être plus
éco-responsables cette friandise serait
le deuxième déchet le plus produit sur
la planète après les mégots de
cigarettes et prendrait cinq ans à se
bio dégradé
je pense qu'il va avoir de plus en plus
de place dans cette industrie-là pour
des joueurs qui vont avoir des valeurs
qui vont être responsables qui vont
amené quelque chose de différent qui est
à ce qu'on soit tenu de la payer plus
cher on nous donne éco-responsable on va
repartir de la substance naturelle va
faire attention à son packaging à ses
modes de transport il y a d'autres
compagnies qui commencent à utiliser
vraiment des serves naturelles c'est
comme là sont souvent plus dispendieuses
on met des allégations justement pour
dire qu'ils sont complètement source
naturelle des allégations il y en a de
toutes sortes sur les emballages les
arguments pour accrocher les
consommateurs ne manquent pas c'est en
compagnie du docteur Félix Girard que
nous en avons validé quelques-uns
est-ce qu'un produit qui a fait chouette
serait plus efficace pour le blanchiment
des dents
on voit dans la liste d'ingrédients
qu'un peu de bicarbonate de soude et
également dans l'instruction ainsi c'est
écrit blanchissant pour moi c'est une
idée que la gomme va avoir un effet
mécanique qui va faire pareil que les
dents plus blanches parce qu'on enlève
des dépôts c'est un nettoyage qui s'agit
un produit c'est une gamme à marcher
sans sucre elle va provoquer la
salivation à l'usage donc on mastique la
gomme ça produit de la salivation c'est
logique que c'est un action sur la
bouche sèche mais est-ce que cette gomme
là particulier va avoir cette action là
plus qu'une autre gomme sans sucre je ne
sais pas comment un sucre alcool peut
réduire les caries pour faire vraiment
attention avec ce qu'on entend par
réduction de risque au niveau individuel
parce que malgré que des preuves dans
des essais cliniques qui montrent qu'il
y en a une réduction du risque de carie
l'analyse reste à faire donc il faut pas
donner une impression une fausse
sécurité face aux produits aujourd'hui
plusieurs produits de gomme sans sucre
qui n'ont aucun impact sur la
progression des caries dentaires qui
vont pas causer l'apparition ou la
progression qui arrive en terre donc oui
il existe des gommes sécuritaires en ce
qui concerne la carie dentaire
on ne peut pas en dire autant de la
bonne vieille gomme balloon sucrée au
sirop de maïs qui ne perd pas en
popularité chez les petits et les grands
mais si on l'avale prendra-t-elle des
années à se digérer comme le veut la
légende urbaine
si on l'avale ça va être à peu près le
même temps que un grain de maïs qu'on
mange qui prend un certain temps digérer
et qu'on n'est pas capable de digérer et
qu'on le voit la fin du processus donc à
peu près le même la même durée ça peut
prendre quelques jours mais non la gomme
ne va pas rester pendant 7 ans
[Musique]